do you ever imagine your own funeral I
do in fact it may be something I think
about a little bit too much given my age
and health and happiness but as someone
with an interest in liturgy and an
inclination towards self-reflection
imagining and even planning my own
funeral is a fascinating possibility
fairs that I Britain be used let there
be liturgical dance but photos will
surface who will attend who will speak
and most importantly what will they say
I hope they will say that I loved they
may speak about my academic not
irritable or resentful it does not
rejoice in wrongdoing but rejoices in
the truth love bears all things believes
all things hopes all things endures all
things love never ends ah we could bask
in the beauty of Paul's ode to love all
day this is an incredibly evocative
description of love and for many of us
it brings to mind romantic love this
passage is often read at weddings and
with februari 14th only two weeks away
we are surrounded by eternal devotion
declared on candy hearts shop windows
full of pink prepackaged romance and
invitations to speed dating at gypsy
but Paul is writing about more than
romantic love he is writing about the
love of a whole community a community
composed of people very different from
one another poor and rich female and
male liberal and conservative
politically socially and theologically
and Paul is exhorting them all to love
one another when we listen to this
description of love with this context in
mind we realize how difficult and
demanding real love is love is patient
love is kind love is not envious
boastful arrogant or rude love does not
insist on its own way love is not
irritable or resentful love does not
rejoice in wrongdoing but rejoices in
the truth love bears all things believes
all things hopes all things endures all
things love never ends is there no
escape suddenly love has become a lot
more challenging suddenly love is not a
warm fuzzy feeling or even a deep
abiding commitment suddenly love is
about everything we do everything we
think everything we feel our attitudes
our habits our actions our beliefs our
hopes love is demanded in every aspect
of our lives and love is not only about
one romantic partner but about everyone
friends family enemies the people we
don't even know exist this radical love
described by Paul is mysterious we can
only know it in part we can only see it
through a mirror dimly we can only
glimpse shadowy reflections of this love
but these shadowy reflections are the
most important thing in the world we can
glimpse this love by looking at the
people in our lives and in our faith
traditions who embody love we can
glimpse this love by telling the real
love stories
my former pastor and colleague Joelle
showed me what it means to love in the
most mundane and ordinary moments Joelle
took time with each person he
encountered to make that person feel
like they mattered the custodian at
church the photographer at the reception
the other passenger in the elevator the
quiet youth on the fringes of the church
youth group and the rebel who everyone
else had already given up on sure well
was often late and I will admit that
people who are late normally really
annoy me but was so well it didn't
bother me quite as much because I
suspected that he was late because he
had stopped to listen to someone who
needed to talk or taken that extra
moment to acknowledge that a service
worker was a person not a machine love
is patient love is kind love takes time
for people no matter what who has shown
you love that is patient and kind Jesus
returned to his hometown stood up in
front of the religious community that
raised him and declared i am the
fulfillment of scripture I am the
Messiah we heard about this in the
glorious gospel reading last week and
this week we heard the results members
of Jesus community ran him out of town
and threatened to throw him off a cliff
this is the good news of the gospel love
is about speaking the truth even when
it's risky love is about saying the
things that you just aren't supposed to
say love is not always about being nice
love rejoices in the truth even the hard
truth no matter what who has given you a
glimpse of love that rejoices in the
truth
this community at university church has
also taught me about love you are some
of the most talented and impressive
people I have ever met I tremble at the
thought of your resumes and soon many of
you will have a label permanently
attached to your name that will declare
to the world you are exceptional at the
same time you have shown me what it
means to love in ways that are not
boastful or arrogant or rude some of you
have shown love through the questions
you asked and your readiness to learn
some of you have shown love through your
openness to trying new things even
things you might not be good at some of
you have shown love through your
willingness to help out with no
expectation of recognition or reward
love is not boastful or arrogant or rude
love is humble no matter what you have
accomplished who has given you a glimpse
of humble love
my grandma and grandpa were married in
1942 I remember the huge party
celebrating their 50th wedding
anniversary in 1992 I had a brand-new
pink dress and helped decorate their
cars with colorful flowers and streamers
over the following 10 years my
grandfather's health began to fail my
grandparents moved out of their house
and into a condo eventually my
grandfather moved into the nursing home
next door my grandfather my grandmother
walked over every day to visit him when
my grandparents celebrated their 61st
wedding anniversary in 2003 both my
grandmother and grandfather were very
ill the night before my grandmother died
she had a lucid moment and a nurse
recorded her words she spoke of her love
for her children and grandchildren and
of her love for her husband even though
he could no longer read the newspaper at
first I found these last words tragic my
grandmother's final thoughts of my
grandfather were about how he was no
longer the man he used to be now I hear
it differently my grandmother's last
words were about how much she loved my
grandfather despite and because he was
no longer the man she had married 61
years before within a week of my
grandmother's death my grandfather also
passed away after more than six decades
how could they be apart love endures
love survives challenge and change no
matter what who has given you a glimpse
of love without indoors
Dirk Willems was one of my forebearers
in faith in the Mennonite faith
tradition he was a 16th century church
leader in the Netherlands who was
imprisoned on account of his beliefs
after being in prison for a year Dirk
escaped he was pursued across a frozen
river by a prison guard and after he had
safely reached the far bank he heard a
loud crack behind him the ice had broken
and the guard had fallen through into
the frigid water Dirk hesitated for only
a second before turning around inching
across the ice and extending his hand to
his captor he pulled the guard safely to
shore and the guard wanted to let dirt
go but his supervisor arrived and called
out to him to halt Dirk the guard
returned Dirk to prison and he was
burned at the stake several months later
Dirk Williams died for his faith a faith
that taught him that the lives of his
enemies were worth saving even at the
cost of his own life love does not
insist on its own way love puts the
other person first no matter what who
has given you a glimpse of love but does
not insist on its own way
after hearing these stories how can I
even hope to embody a fraction of the
love lived out by these individuals and
communities how can I presume to suggest
that at my funeral people would
celebrate that I loved I am overwhelmed
by my own failure to love and by a world
that so often seems so inhospitable to
love and then I remember that love is
not all about me sometimes it may feel
like it's all about me my feelings my
thoughts my desires my actions but love
is not all about me at other times it
feels like love is all about other
people about putting the feelings
thoughts desires and actions of others
first but love is not all about other
people either love is all about God love
is all about God being all about
everyone it is about God loving other
people in God loving me and especially
about God bringing you and me and us and
them together because love is all about
God being all about everyone love can
never be separated from justice or
forgiveness regardless of what I believe
in this moment about God and whether God
exists or as powerful or good love is
still about God love is something beyond
and within us something that moves us
towards one another something that moves
us towards our most honest selves this
kind of God this kind of love is
something to celebrate God's love
revealed in human love is something to
celebrate so we celebrate the love of
joelle and Jesus and university church
and my grandparents and Dirk and all of
the other people who have given us
glimpses of God's love we celebrate love
that is patient and kind love that
rejoices in the truth love that is
humble love that indoors love that does
not insist on its own way
love that bears all things believes all
things hopes all things love that never
ends we celebrate God's love reflected
in human love in every moment of life
love present when sperm meets egg when
lungs meet air when parents meet child
when child meets friends when youth
fleet enemies when people meet passions
when partner needs partner when age
meets wisdom when body needs earth when
spirit needs spirit love never ends this
is the type of love I hope friends and
family will celebrate at my funeral this
is the type of love I hope to celebrate
in every moment of my life this is the
type of love I hope our life together
can celebrate God is this love this is
God's love amen
you